foreign
Philadelphia Pennsylvania Tammy is there
Tammy how can we help
hey good afternoon
um calling to see if you can help I have
a situation that just seems to not
exactly be improving I've got an aunt
that this is the third time
um third time now just recently she's
messaged me asking for money because
they're tight on cash
um the past two times that she's asked
it's been like a thousand dollars here
and there
um
and she paid it back when she has
the first time she offered interest
second time she just paid back the full
amount I'm just getting to the point
where I I don't feel comfortable
how much longer do I keep doing this the
story just keeps dragging out like
doesn't seem to be
there doesn't seem to be an end to it no
there won't be either because you're a
bank for her
you know she came to you the first time
I will say this I'm I'm I'm pleasantly
surprised that she's paid you back both
times that's the most shocking part I
was really surprised to hear that uh but
she's not going to change her habits
because she knows or at least she
believes up to this very moment that
when she gets in a tight pinch she comes
and tells you a story and she plays on
your emotions and you help her out but
the fact of the matter is this isn't
about her this is about you and your
life and you're not feeling good about
it so you know the answer is uh
Aunt Peggy or whatever her name is I'll
just call her that you know I'm not
giving you money anymore
I don't feel good about it
and I'm not going to do it
I definitely I'm not going to I feel
like this is the time that I say no to
her
but how do I do that very clearly I say
no very quickly do it kindly but do it
firmly
yeah you don't have to be a jerk about
it okay and Tammy you you are not a jerk
you are a very nice person but Tammy
what you're actually afraid of is not
what you're gonna say it's how she's
going to react that's exactly right you
are really worried about it exactly and
that is something that is completely out
of your control and so the hardest thing
to do about this whole situation is
Letting Go the idea that you have
control of the outcome
because she could say exactly well we're
family and I can't believe you do this
to me and oh my gosh you're dead to me
now and she severs the relationship
that's really a worst case scenario
right
yep but if the entire relationship was
based on these transactions there was no
relationship to begin with
exactly yeah and that's sort of how I'm
feeling well Tammy here's the deal I
think here's your choice
would you rather disappoint Aunt Peggy
or would you rather resent her
yeah I'm starting to resent her I know
I'm asking you to answer the question
this is a would you rather and it's
rather mild all right would you rather
disappoint her by saying kindly but
firmly as George said it very clearly
not going to give you money anymore
would you rather disappoint her or would
you rather resent her more than you
already resent her which the one do you
want to choose long term
yeah I'd rather discipline her that's
the choice and our friend Dr John
deloney quotes another psychologist when
he says choose guilt over resentment
every time
yeah that's that's the choice because
the resentment is a poison
the guilt we can deal with
but that resentment is going to sever
the relationship more than anything and
so it's going to be a hard conversation
we're not trying to belittle that uh you
know don't mince the words just say I'm
so sorry I can no longer provide money
for you I'd love to help you get on a
budget and give you some resources to do
that maybe you gift her The Total Money
Makeover we'll gift one to you if you
think she'll read it but if she's not
willing to deal with the underlying
behaviors then you're just an enabler in
this situation
exactly and I don't I definitely don't
want to be that so do you recommend
because this is like she's always
requested the money over text and it's
just easy transaction obviously yeah
text it um do I text her back or do I is
this like a phone call situation do you
recommend I think next time she texts
you you give her a call and explain yeah
because over text there's no tone and so
it's easy to take things the wrong way
I'd much rather say I wanted to go jump
on a call real quick I know you sent me
the text here's the situation that's a
very good point but I mean here's the
deal
she you have to start this conversation
by saying hey this is going to be very
difficult this is not an easy thing for
me to do but I've decided you need to
use words like that so before we
actually lay it out there
she understands exactly what's going on
and if she senses any weakness she's
going to pounce I promise you that's a
great Point like Timmy you have to be
decided yeah like you have before you
even have the conversation you've got to
go it doesn't matter what she says what
she does how she reacts I am choosing
this
for me and I've made the choice the
decision's been made this is all about
communicating a decision does that make
sense
yes yeah it does that's definitely and
Tammy listen to me no because you keep
there's nothing more on this because you
keep coming back you're so concerned
about what she's going to do and I get
it but here's what you need to
understand Tammy that no matter what
your aunt does or says as a result of
this you are not a bad person
okay I want you to say that right now I
am not a bad person say it
I am not a bad person all right then
believe it and George this is why
for years decades Dave and now we carry
that torch this money loaning family
members money getting involved in money
issues it just oh it's a recipe for
disaster Thanksgiving is already awkward
enough isn't it true between politics
and sports let's not bring money into it
and go hey uh you remember you owe me
that money can't yeah and she always
gonna get it to you yeah and now she
starts avoiding you yeah oh
let's be very clear I I get Tammy you
know who knows what we didn't dig into
what the relationship is you know is it
the sister of you know whatever but you
know this idea of disappointing any
family member family family member is
very very difficult to think about
agreed but then they're you're worried
about the damage they're gonna do
why are they gonna go tell the half the
side of the family
you know oh you're not gonna believe
this
you know it's just like you feel like
it's a no-win situation agreed and
there's that's not the case there's a
reason she went to to her niece she
knows other people in her life are gonna
go kick rocks and pound sand I'm not
gonna just gonna keep giving you money
but when it comes to Tammy's a very nice
person very and uh you know there's a
book out there called No More Mr Nice
Guy and it's for people who tend to be
people Pleasers and they want to make
people happy they don't want to make
people feel bad they want to be liked
and that can cause us to do things that
cause us to be resentful yeah and I'm
one of those people Pleasers recovering
have you read the book I have yeah you
like it amazing read yeah there you go
there's a good recommendation right
there uh for those of you who feel that
you know because that's a tough Bond
break you know where you feel bonded to
family or friends that you always have
to say yes oh it's tough that's one of
the hardest things but we're not trying
to belittle it but it's a it's as simple
as it sounds and as hard as it sounds
really tough stuff well Tammy thank you
so much for uh calling in and trusting
us and hang in there do what's best for
you choose you in this situation and let
the chips fall where they may thanks
again for the call